hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to among the sleep
where a little child has wandered into a
hellscape unlike any other but we got a
teddy bear on our side and you guys
watching so I don't think I'll be very
scared
climb over a little kid I'm sure you're
not gonna get harmed much somehow I
don't think that's a playhouse it's like
the witch's house in the woods it's made
of candy except it's not made of candies
mad at nightmares or maybe candy maybe
there's candy inside I'm not exactly
sure this is uncharted territory
I might be able to open it from the
inside if you help me up no Teddy I
can't risk losing you so let me shove
you through the hole as fast as I can
nevermind I guess it wasn't that urgent
Teddy okay what is it what is it all is
this my inner darkness well ok let's
unlock it open yes good idea maybe I
need to put you in there huh
maybe by the pipes that may seem how it
is no no no no no no no no no no no no
no ok all right don't no no I don't want
to lose you Teddy okay good I thought
you're gonna climb in there and you're
gonna be little do it out of here with
that work
I don't know it is I'm - is it made of
solid gold it is very valuable how about
we burn it up alive it seems like an
appropriate use so I shut the door
squeak turn the crank errs come on Oh
fancying it quite oh did I looks like
you need more doodads it's fine Dewayne
to open it okay what about this thing on
the bottom there what the hell is that
shaped like a teddy and what is that
sound the sound of nightmares coming
from that door hello doesn't kill you
Wow what did it do what did it do teddy
bear okay if we can find more memories
like this it might bring us to her Wow
or I could just we need three more yeah
you're spot-on there you are a genius
teddy bear tonight mare's scares me a
lot
I'll do my best to keep you safe thanks
teddy me up whenever you're ready to go
I'm ready now
thanks teddy are you gonna turn evil by
the end of this because I have a bad
feeling that I'm gonna be betrayed by
you betrayed at two years old kind of
scarring life am i leading here oh I'm
very eager to get into this new stuff
because I remember though among the
sleep demo a while ago and it really was
very very interesting and somehow this
this full release actually added the one
I already played even though I'd already
seen it before okay that's good best to
announce my presence all the monsters
that may or may not be ahead of me so
that they know that there is a meal
walking into their mouths crawling
crawling on my belly that is exactly
what you're not supposed to say in these
horror game movie situations sir
too bad it's Teddy in the baby dingo and
the baby except it's a teddy bear e and
the baby
Mary put Berry in the baby up and that
nice what it's that okay what did I just
get obviously unclogged it and it was
some sort of an owl is your Rasmus
Rasmus from hotline Miami is this is
beginning of that character how insane
he was this would explain it indeed god
this is pretty can I just say that this
is really really pretty
lot of detail went into this god I love
it I love it I love it so much over
there it looks like another memory
across that bridge okay
so what's it gonna take to get over to
it what sacrifices do I need to make
that looks like amber from fringe not
that it was my favorite show but I did
appreciate it we okay delay on the weed
I weed a little too early hello you're
way up this tower
I found another owl maybe that'll help
me I got tools now I got a pair of
hooters over here does anyone want to
use my hooters okay I need to find 4
more hooters yeah I shouldn't be too
hard
babies need hooters for various reasons
mostly nutrition hi okay I failed on
that one thought I was gonna make it but
didn't so ok fell little kitty fell fell
what is that oh my goodness if I do that
I am a disturbed little child here that
I've got some possession going on in my
brain which would explain a lot hobbit
stop falling it's very disturbing
ok got it oh boy
hey-ho telly did I just
Oh telly telly telly thank you oh thank
you thank you for opening that I tip my
hat to thee sir or madam never hunting
Oh what should we make our vault is
there some dastardly demons oh there's a
lovely sound of children playing I can't
wait to join them in hell okay try to
climb up this maybe Oh can't little kid
can't do it crawling on the belly
I'll crawl crawl still don't know why I
need to be careful I'm assuming that
they're gonna be monsters at some point
got my shoulders got tensed up there I
didn't even notice it this must be the
return point I guess I go the other way
and I come back around after I pull
another owl out of the socket there is
that my footsteps Oh was that some mouse
cuz I know much appreciate it I'm a baby
on the edge don't wanna mess with me
throw my teddy a and then I'll cry for
my mama
there's bad things it's getting louder
why the hell is it getting louder don't
say anything I just look for a hooter
can I please get a howl thank you wasn't
what I wanted thank you it's always
important to be polite you're facing
demons from another dimension
and the madness of my own mind even as a
child what movies did this kid see as
Kenneth's been exposed to inappropriate
behavior and/or television and as you
can see his mind is just gone wasted
youth okay why does a child be subjected
to this why must I a man baby be
subjected to this okay what have we got
here yeah you seem to be very worried
about my mama ha but uh how about you
worry about me for a little bit there Oh
a precipice into death I can't wait to
walk towards that owl I'm sure it won't
be a trap again come here whoo-hoo come
here whoo it's won't fall at all oh that
smell something teddy oh it's a big
whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo over there okay hello
what's wrong with you oh the hell's
wrong with you hey move it
move it I like to move it I like to get
out of here
thank you die don't you dare you get me
out of here all right I found another
whoo-hoo I got another pair of hooters I
just need two more I think I got
sidetracked because I want another way
but I'm gonna go over yonder whoo [ __ ]
okay fell down cuz I'm a baby and I
can't walk I forgot I'm more of a
toddler than a baby actually this looks
very death trap all that is another big
owl that was that rocky before going on
over here how am I supposed to do that
I'm just a baby get that oh I see bunk
that was one heavy tire but it did the
job there God do you think these puzzles
were set up for a little kid to say okay
you think these puzzles are set up for a
little kid to solve them maybe maybe not
maybe I am okay some ding loud maybe
don't you do that tonight all right what
am I got over here I got us something I
can climb on sir point to that where do
I get over to the other place there
another whoo-hoo over here can I climb
up on this I can I'm supposed to go
around huh
yeah too smart for you oh there's
another whoo-hoo okay I think that's the
last one just get over here I don't even
know if I'm supposed to go that way but
it did take a look another piece of my
great work that I did as a child genius
artist what do we got here
oh I'm sorry okay y'all you see you're
very serious about your artwork an you
don't want me looking at it last hey can
you shut up there is a creepy ass baby
over there and almost careful alright
that's cool
can we never do that again what the hell
was that the bad thing is I have no idea
what to expect in this game Daniel oh
boy they're staring at me
okay den the box now it's gonna be a
teeter totters that I can walk on okay
it's gonna be enough leverage that I can
actually walk up here and climb up seems
a little dangerous for a child okay now
I don't think anyone cares I can scream
that from the mountaintops but
apparently no one cares Wow
this is nightmarish I can't wait to sell
find my mom by the time I get to my mom
my mom's never gonna recognize me you
know from all the murder it's gonna
happen to me from all the scarring and
you know the demon let's get up well
that's me
my mom's not gonna like it when my
head's starting to spin round and round
and around over and over again hello
who's how you doing Hooten have a storm
Hootie and the Blowfish okay I don't
know how many pop-culture references I
can make oh that's pretty
oh that reminds me of a time when I was
happy and things weren't trying to kill
me I wonder when that was I don't quite
remember when that was must have been
forever ago I lean off this kid is two
years old I started playing horror games
two years ago maybe he represents my
inner childhood this is just the
culmination of what horrible okay
alright then one more time
but that's it thanks mom mom oh hi mom
you look weird so I'm right with you
hey goodbye thanks
oh good it's a rainbow and musical
finally we must be getting closer
probably not if I had to guess I would
guess that we were probably not making
it to the end maybe some bonding I hear
that
let me let me sing happy fun times oh
god this game is so creepy
we me oh hello you're slightly
disturbing thank you we made it back to
where we're in the name err world now
you're not sure because I'm not sure
that you're not evil okay
come on long teddy bear the evil inside
your head
all of this evilness started when you
came around unless those pictures or
something to indicate that I may have
been evil long time ago am I supposed to
spell something with those because I
have know what kind of kids block has an
ie symbol I don't know we have to find a
way to safety
yes by the way out of this mess yes I
agree I agree 100% they need to find
three more items this might break up
very evenly what about my mama don't you
talk bad about my mama
I'll get very grumpy about my ol hello
my so worried maybe but don't be afraid
I wasn't you and me we'll work this all
out
okay I know you know we will you know
the ropes but now possibly God I swear
there is a ever so slight sinister tone
to your voice mister and those beady
little eyes don't stay well they stare
into my soul but they don't fool me I
know something is wrong with you you
want me to burn up all these memories
for some strange reason and I don't know
why also I don't know why I have the
intellectual capacity to understand what
you're trying to tell me to do but
whatever kept going around and around
and around come on come on there we go
burn it up send it over sounds
suspiciously like okay thank you
Thank You teddy bear it sounds
suspiciously like screaming
yes she sounds clearer now don't you
think
come on we have no time to lose I got a
lot to lose time is the least of my
concern here I know I'll be ready when
I'm ready so neither way I'm gonna end
this episode here now I'm gonna pick it
right back up where I left off so either
way thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done let me know in the
comments below if you think that teddy
bear is evil because I do not like it
and as always I will see you in the next
video